the IPO Provos is one of the most
sparsely populated regions in the south
of France
farming dominates here and that attracts
gourmets the municipality of shut Donal
Sanibel this is where star chef Jenny
glaze has his kitchen garden he took
over the restaurant from his father
years ago more than 40 different herbs
grow on the 300 square metre plot
located right next to his restaurant
let's see you know show some don't see
it this garden is a stroke of luck it
inspires me it smells so good here it
always gives me good ideas the scent
goes to my brain and makes me dream and
I try to realize those dreams on a plate
just 15 kilometers away is the town of
sista Hall its Citadel is a popular
tourist destination the surrounding
hills are famous for assists of all lamb
their meat is a well-known delicacy with
its own quality label the Lambs are
raised until they're 75 to 150 days old
spending their short lives entirely
outdoors sit down on your protectors who
said man's lamb is milk fed by its
mother don't curse in severely the fat
is white and firm the meat is fine and
tender and that is because of the way
it's been raised and it has to be young
good lamb is always young lamb la Bonita
Jenni glasses restaurant has had a
Michelin star for years it belongs to a
small four-star hotel with 18 rooms the
estate has been owned by the family for
generations
sister whole lamb is a specialty here
replicate the news you know she will be
making a blanket Daniel lamb ragout it's
a simple family recipe you can make it
with me from the shoulder or neck or
breast of this excellent land with or
without the bone God knows who's he
the lamb is sprinkled with seasonings
salt and pepper and browned and oil
add cloves of garlic to the casserole
followed by celery and lots of olive oil
then come fresh herbs from the garden
Jenny CLA's has chosen savory bay leaves
and arugula blossoms should avoid those
things marketed as herbs of Provence
they're ready mixed ones even if you
don't have an herbal garden you should
try to use individual herbs and mix them
according to your own taste add water to
the ingredients and cover simmer for 20
minutes to an hour depending on how
tender the lamb is in the meantime
prepare vegetables like onions carrots
and potatoes once the lamb is cooked
thicken the meat juice from the
casserole with a flour roux adding some
cream gives the sauce its white color
the term blanket comes from the French
word blush or white here are full of
tastes and sense you find savory thyme
rosemary so the meat from the Lambs is
already aromatic the sister hole LeBlanc
a to the nude this is tall
so the real herbs of the provost's are
the secret of the sister Hong Lam the
dishes best enjoyed was a glass of red
wine